922 tage lang quälte von marvin aus
duisburg jede spur
am ende juli 2017 wird der damals
13-jährige schüler zum letzten mal an
diesem kiosk gesehen im
nordrhein-westfälischen oer-erkenschwick
dort lebt man in einer
jugendhilfeeinrichtung weil es zu hause
probleme gegeben hatte die polizei
versucht den jungen unter anderem über
sein handy zu orten ohne erfolg marvins
mutter manuela beginnt die schlimmste
zeit ihres lebens auf facebook und in
der fernsehsendung aktenzeichen xy sucht
sie nach ihrem sohn zu schreiben
in ihrer not wendet sie sich sogar an
einen hellseher der behauptet im januar
2009 10er könne marvin tot im wald
liegen sehen die polizei sucht mit
spürhunden an der angegebenen stelle
findet aber nichts tatsächlich gefunden
wird der junge dann am 20
dezember 2009 10 durch einen zufall
wegen schwerer sexualstraftaten
ermittelt die polizei in einem haus an
der hochstraße in recklinghausen in der
wohnung von lars h suchen die beamten
eigentlich nach kinderpornografie nach
abbildungen von schwerem sexuellem
kindesmissbrauch
doch dann entdeckten die beamten den
vermissten marvin in einem schrank
offenbar hatten der 44 jährige lars h
und dessen 77 jähriger vater den
teenager versteckt als die polizei an
der tür klingelt gegen lars h wird
haftbefehl erlassen
später kommt heraus bei der suche nach
marvin gab es offenbar eine
ermittlungspanne bereits im juli 2009 10
hatte eine zuschauerin von aktenzeichen
xy einen hinweis auf den aufenthaltsort
des jugendlichen gegeben er werde von
einem pädophilen in recklinghausen
festgehalten
die polizei telefoniert daraufhin mit
einem weiteren mann der den beamten
sogar den namen von lars h nimmt doch
der hinweis kam offenbar ohne weitere
ermittlungen zu den akten die
staatsanwaltschaft deshalb
vorermittlungen gegen beamte der
duisburger polizei eingeleitet das habe
sich unterdessen ab heute vor gericht
verantworten
ihm werden vergewaltigung schwerer
sexueller missbrauch mit 472 fälle von
sexuellem missbrauch des jugendlichen
marvin vorgeworfen er hat mein kind 200
jahre entführt hatte alles passiert ist
also ich setze meine ich habe so viel
wut und hass aber ich setze mal sätze
über kraft um und versuche das gerechte
strafe bekommt und sagte da mein ganzes
denken rein und das das ende sein wird
da sagen wir sicher waren kommt und
nunmehr irgendwelchen kindern oder
jugendlichen was antun kann ja und heute
ist wie gesagt der prozessauftakt in
diesem schrecklichen fall reporter
michael engelberg ist mehr zu leicht
zubereitet michael was wird von diesem
ersten verhandlungstag erwartet ja guten
morgen sie na also man muss sagen dass
heute sehr wahrscheinlich nur die
anklage verlesen wird und die hat sehr
sehr viele seiten die ist sehr sehr
umfangreich alleine 4 172 fälle des
sexuellen missbrauchs an kindern das
wird eine sehr sehr lange zeit dauern
man muss aber auch sagen dass das
medieninteresse ja heute sehr sehr groß
ist allerdings in corona zeiten müssen
sich gerichte auch einschränken es sind
nur sechs pressevertreter innerhalb des
saales zugelassen
acht zuschauer darunter auch die mutter
von marvin und wir gehen davon aus dass
eventuell heute zwei zeugen vernommen
werden
aber auch dass lars h sich zu den
vorwürfen erstmal nicht äußern wird
er ist ja angeklagt wegen 475 fachen
missbraucht wie kommt die polizei auf
diese
ich gehe davon aus dass die polizei die
tage zusammengerechnet hat die die
marvin bei lars h gewohnt hat was ja
auch in der anklage zur sprache gekommen
ist dass er gegen kost und logis mit
sexuellen handlungen sich dieses quasi
verkaufen konnte
und dann wird man die zahlen und die
tage zusammen rechnen und dann eine
hochrechnung wagen und dann kommt man
auf die zahlen
ich kann auch sagen als wir damals da
waren als die polizei die die wohnung
von lars h tatsächlich auf links gezogen
haben haben sie sämtliche kartons aus
der wohnung getragen das ganze haus roch
nach urin
einer der eingesetzten entrümpler hatte
mir gesagt so was habe er noch nicht
gesehen und er sei wirklich nicht hatten
sagt besonnen und wir gehen davon aus
dass die anklageverlesung hier heute bis
in den mittag dauert und insgesamt sind
15 verhandlungstage angesetzt durch die
kammern und dann muss man einfach sehen
ob eventuell irgendwann noch die
öffentlichkeit zur aussage des
angeklagten ausgeschlossen wird und wenn
marvin vernommen wird gehe ich auch
davon aus dass dies außerhalb der
hauptverhandlung und außerhalb der
pressevertreter passiert